alors bonjour la planète
vous êtes à l'émission de tam-tam canada
en directement rien du studio 93 on a
beaucoup de studios ici radio canada et
puis ici autour de la table on a
beaucoup de jeunes beaucoup de monde
comme d'habitude on à paloma martinez
bonjour paloma marie-jo d'un bonjour
stéphane marie claude simard bonjour
leonardo simao des scripts je suis un
peu stressée je ne regarde pas ce que
c'est vous chaque leur caste c'est vous
qui allez vas-y tu veux parler à la
planète c'est ça j'ai dit va sillonner
la cei 11 à 11 en est à l'heure comme
ont toujours à l'air nous de notre
émission commence à 11 ans ont fait un
beau bonjour à la planète bonjour
collectif une vague mondiale parce qu'on
a trois caméras ici un studio
aujourd'hui pour ajouter une quatrième
bientôt je pense qu'on préfère la
semaine prochaine enfin on va envoyer le
mémo chef chef chef techniciste
exactement alors aujourd'hui vous allez
devinez ensemble les gens aussi qui sont
de l'autre côté de l'écran qui sont sur
l'internet
bien accrochés à l'internet un peu comme
une sorcière sur son balai vous allez
pouvoir jouer au jeu de la devinette
deviner le sujet des munitions en cinq
images les gens en studio vous vous
prononcez dès que vous sentez que vous
êtes sur la bonne piste
attention il faudra être précis pas
générale voici tant pis ma 5 1
on parle de quoi aujourd'hui téléphone
utilise à son d'une nouvelle technologie
les nouvelles technologies oui ça
pourrait être c'était mieux dans le
téléphone intelligent
rires mais encore ça c'est une belle
image parce que non parce qu'elle dit
tout parce que oui parce que vous pouvez
avec d'une main vous avez une téléphone
intelligent de l'autre mais vous avez
café la cigarette et disparus vous avez
remarqué j'espère y en a plus place
jusqu'à 6h avec son téléphone
intelligent des ordres images montraient
aussi le téléphone dans un monde
merveilleux paradisiaque
donc on met l'accent sur les beaux côtés
du téléphone cellulaire
c'est donc 2 0 c'est un téléphone qui
est en train de nous tuer le service on
oublie ça aujourd'hui
momentanément tout cas pour les
prochaines minutes dans un instant chose
au téléphone intelligent ouais on a un
auditeur quiniou pas un éditeur
spécialiste
peut-être qu'il est auditeur à
l'occasion qui va être avec nous dans
quelques secondes
mais bon on le présente pas tout de
suite ok d'accord on va faire c'est le
roulement de tambour n'avait pas de
boulot tombeau où on a longtemps goûté
de la sonorisation les faire ici
faites donc c'est ça
et on ajoute l'éclairage en tamise c'est
le jeu de la grosse boule première
manche pour présenter notre invité oh
c'est bon pour 20 points
cette première manche de la grosse boule
fin au faux au québec québec
le téléphone portable est interdit dans
les écoles primaires et secondaires vrai
ou faux vrai vrai pour vous pour moi et
secondaire jetez-y ça dépend des écoles
je dirais que peut-être dans certaines
écoles au secondaire il est permis dans
d'autres non vrai ou faux au québec le
téléphone portable est interdit dans les
écoles primaires ou secondaires faux
faux étaient dans la salle de classe est
interdite dans les couloirs nom qui vous
cédez de réponse les dépenses diverses
et puis pierre notre technicien du côté
de la techno sonore vrai ou faux
avez vous parlé au faux pas dans les
classes mais à l'école c'est permis dans
les corridors très bien dans les
toilettes aussi et pas pourquoi c'est
pas partout ailleurs dans ma classe je
sais pas voici la réponse au québec
aucune directive précise n'a été donnée
aux établissements scolaires j'avais dit
faux forfait alors c'est enfin pour vous
c'est 10 points pour vous parce que je
tiens t2 du point moi j'hésite - pouvez
alors vous aimez maryse je sais pas 5
il a tranché
voilà on va rester dans le monde
scolaire puisque notre spécialiste est
rattachée à ce monde mais on le présente
pas encore tout de suite à ce qui est
une vraie sommité en la matière
pour le moment on va pour aider à la
conversation avec lui je vous proposais
cette vidéo avec un élève qui a 15 ans
il a fait beaucoup de bruit
c'était il ya quelques mois alors que il
s'est rebellé contre son école qui
saisissent lé téléphone des étudiants en
classe je pense que vous avez tous
entendu parler de cette soir de tous
temps peu d'entre eux avaient des
enfants à l'école
voilà tous deux simples en mai à l'école
juste quelques uns d'entre eux donc ça
l'université ou au travail cela alors
vous la voici
oui prend la parole tout de suite on va
leur rien bobines et comme dans le bon
vieux temps avec le groupe quasiment
caisse comme alençon
on va donner son nom parce que quand
même c'est essentiel il s'agit de
vincent duguay qui demande qui demandait
aux directions d'école d'une plus
confisquer les cellulaires de ses
copains alors là 15 ans et puis beaucoup
de gens l'ont appuyé au québec on va
l'entendre une entrevue qu'il a accordée
à radio-canada à une émission du matin
et récemment
et puis après ça on va pas rendre plus
de quatre heures pour toutes sortes de
raison que ce soit les parents veulent
pas signer le papier ou un accord avec
la direction
et donc j'ai décidé de faire quelque
chose parce que je trouve que de laisser
faire ça mais ça dépend des confesseurs
près de 20 seulement si vous l'utilisez
pour confisquer magnan n'ont que ça va
je suis sur le coin de bureau vous
l'avez pas serré dans vos poches
ils prennent ils confisquent lorsqu'on
est le remède à la direction vous avez
une feuille à faire si le rapport le
lendemain matin c'est que lorsque ça se
passe vendredi
vous l'avez seulement le love et i donc
là on a presque trois jours de
confiscation ticket pas du tout lien
avec une infraction qui commise connaît
alors voilà c'est ce qu'on me confie
secoue aujourd'hui à notre époque ont
confisqué autre chose les les coups de
poing américain
mettez roche les temps ont bien changé
mais juste là pour dire que peut-être
que ce jeune dans le fin fond des choses
ce qu'il dit et essence et peut-être
qu'on va trouver ni trop rapide en tire
la gâchette trop rapidement en en
voulant enlever dans certaines écoles
l'accès des jeunes aux télés après tout
des fois ils sont importants c'est
téléphone pour que les parents restent
en contact avec leurs enfants
on va parler de tout ça des bienfaits
pédagogique que du téléphone cellulaire
en classe avec thierry karsenti
professeur titulaire à la chaire de
recherche du canada sur des technologies
de l'information et de la communication
en éducation à l'université de montréal
bonjour professeur yao quelques semaines
des bienfaits de des tablettes à l'école
mais l'outil principal de communication
ça demeure le téléphone cellulaire ou
est-ce qu'on en est présentement au
niveau des interdictions on a parlé du
québec
est ce qu'on peut avoir un portrait de
comment ça se passe ici au canada puis
ailleurs dans le monde interdit ailleurs
et donc il n'ya pas de réglementation
officielle par des pc ce sont les écoles
qui vont décider des comprimés pour ce
qu'ils appellent à boycotter jusqu'à
environ la troisième secondaire par
contre alors donc c'est une bataille
perdue d'avancé
donc c'est est ce qu'on arrive quand
même à l'entente
oui d'accord comme s'ils étaient sur un
téléphone arabe ces téléphones avec les
deux canettes ou les deux boîtes de
conserve avec un fils c'est un peu le
son qu'on a en ce moment avec le
professeur karsenti donc est ce que vous
nous entendez bien professeur de votre
côté à tout le moins au pétrole on a
envoyé la fusée numéro 1 vers la lune il
ya en effet envoyé la numéro 2 de
toiture en sont atteintes en deux
phrases parce que vous manquez
essentiellement vous avez dit que c'est
un combat perdu d'avancé que dans
plusieurs pays on a adopté une
interdiction dans la plupart des classes
ou dans les classes c'est plus complexe
que ça il faut comprendre il faut
chercher des solutions mais pour moi
l'interdiction n'est pas la bonne
solution l'histoire de l'humanité nous
montrent interdire simplement sans
confronter une problème on n'est pas en
train de résoudre on est en train de
reporter le problème à plus tard et puis
le problème il est présent le pourquoi
hachey grandes écoles que l'école de
vincent duguet qu'est ce qui s'est passé
dans cette école à l'école charles
gravel
on avait un problème avec les
cellulaires on a décidé de confisquer et
lui je pense pas qu'il était pour ou
contre les usages éducatif il s'est
juste dit que sur un plan
constitutionnel on n'a pas le droit de
confisquer les biens que ça représente
un danger donc sur le principe il avait
raison maintenant ça résout pas le
problème non plus qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire avec ça et donc l'idée c'est que
je pense en tout cas ce qui fonctionne
le mieux c'est quand on amène élèves et
enseignants réfléchir ensemble sur des
règles parce qu'il faut des règles avec
les cellulaires c'est trop tentant pour
des jeunes
vous savez on a 13 ans est assise au
secondaire pour nous enseigne direct de
grammaire ou des problèmes de
mathématiques on reçoit des
notifications sur facebook sur snapshot
qu'est-ce qu'on va choisir et c'est très
difficile de choisir les mathématiques
le français parmi l'éventail de règles
qui pourraient être appliquées est-ce
que vous en connaissez certainement
canada qui ont été testées et qui semble
tenir la route
mais il faut comprendre deux choses et
aller à une certaine époque on en voyait
que des textos des sms comme 10 en
france avec les téléphones cellulaires
c'était donc plus facile peut-être de
contenir le problème mais actuellement
avec les téléphones intelligents c'est
internet ce sont les réseaux sociaux
avec les notifications vous savez il ya
beaucoup d' études en psychologie qui
montrent que les notifications nous
rendent heureux on est content de
recevoir un texto on est content de
recevoir une notification et comme les
jeunes sont sur slap shade facebook et
instagram surtout en termes de
notification ça leur aurait plus ou
moins 300 par jour +3 100 textos
ça complique lente que c'est ça rend la
tension en salle de classe vraiment
vraiment délicate et donc l'interdiction
ne résout pas le problème est en jeu les
écoles où ça se passe le mieux
on réfléchit avec les jeunes autour de
son temps de les sensibiliser à de
meilleurs usages en classe on tente
d'avoir aussi certains usages
pédagogiques donc on ne fait pas juste
interdiront leur manque parfois ça peut
être utilisé pour on se plaint que dans
les écoles n'est pas assez d'ordinateurs
donc le téléphone portable finalement le
téléphone intelligent c'est une forme de
petit ordinateur donc les élèves vont
sur internet font des recherches mais il
ya dans toutes ses classes là si on veut
avoir pleinement l'attention des élèves
est ce que l'on a pu observer dans nos
recherches qui fonctionne vraiment bien
c'est quand on demande à tous les jeunes
de sortir leur cellulaire delà de leur
poche de le mettre à l'envers sur le
bureau des pins taux de vibrations lors
de certains qui l'auront pas
discrètement sinon ils sont tous en
train de discrètement de texter de
répondre à des nouvelles c'est vraiment
complexe pour eux c'est très tentant à
cesser c'est pas évident et même pour
les adultes n'est pas évident non plus
alors messieurs oui moi je me portais
des questions parce que c'est bien
communiquer avec des outils comme les
téléphones cellulaires
il faut aussi apprendre à communiquer
avec les gens donc écouter quelqu'un qui
nous présente un point de vue peut-être
avec lequel on n'est pas d'accord mais
il faut écouter comprendre et ensuite
pour une question et je pense que
monsieur karsenti vous ces problèmes de
la tension et de la compréhension et de
l'acquisition des connaissances
le problème d'attention et les complexes
les technologies rendent complexe le
monde de la tension vous savez que vous
allez faire une recherche sur internet
et google prend un malin plaisir à vous
dire que ça a pris
3.2 secondes à trouver quelque chose ça
dépasse rarement 4 secondes et même
souvent starbucks de seconde alors vous
demander à des jeunes qui ont cette
habitude d'instantanéité d'être patient
salles de classe et d'attendre c'est
tout un défi et et l'idée de la
communication je comprends votre point
de vue que c'est important de parler en
personne en face à face mais souvent on
dit que ces jeunes sont isolés avec les
technologies on voit des jeunes qui
texte a dit sami différents parallèle
dans le métro et on voit des personnes
qui les regarde avec un regard sévère
qu'est ce qu'il put sun la personne qui
tenterait next avec six amis ou la
personne qui est ce là non mais c'est
tout un débat c'est pas aussi tranchée
que ça ça veut dire
cet isolement il ya beaucoup de
recherches qui montrent au contraire le
téléphone cellulaire et des technologies
vient briser cet isolement parce qu'on
est en contact oui en contact
virtuellement est ce qu on veut ne faire
que des contacts virtuels se ne pense
que non mais c'est pas vrai qu'il ya pas
de contact c'est pas vrai qu'il ya pas
de bienfaits autour de ça mais comment
on apprend la patience à faire des
contacts avec des gens si on est
toujours gratifié à travers nos outils
technologiques
est ce que ça ne vient pas comme une
drogue oui mais c'est je vous dis pas
qu'il faut pas à développer la patience
et la tension et puis moi je pense que
c'est au contraire extrêmement important
plus la diction textos quand on regarde
c'est le nombre moyen de textos envoyés
par mois chez les 13-17 au québec c'est
environ 6200 6200 par mois c'est mais
c'est pas juste une drogue chez les
jeunes regardent et les adultes avec les
réseaux sociaux les notifications et ses
proches de chez eux donc saviez bouscule
it complètement les valeurs la façon
dont on fonctionne dans la société et
apprendre la patience oui c'est pas
simple les jeunes et les adultes aussi
des sont de moins en moins patient et
dès qu'on attend 30 secondes on sort son
téléphone et on voit regardez qu'est ce
qui se passe en parallèle on n'arrive
plus à avoir des moments de transition
silencieuse est donc cette attention
faut l'apprendre parallèlement à ça
peut-être aussi qu'il ya des problèmes à
l'école peut être on aborde une école
qui est un peu déconnecté de cette ville
et je ne peux être que les techniques
ne sont pas aussi présente pour ça je
vous dit l'interdiction tout selon moi
ne fonctionne pas les écoles où ça se
passe le mieux c'est quand on ne tentait
de responsabiliser les élèves
maintenant je vous dis ça mais ça reste
quand même deux cellulaires un défi de
chaque instant on les responsabilise on
leur permet d'utiliser par moments
d'autres moments demande vraiment de les
voir parce que si les élèves giuly je
les range et ne vous inquiétez pas c'est
certain qu'ils vont le sortir
discrètement on a filmé dans des salles
de classe on veut les élèves qui disent
oui avec la tête et puis c'est pas juste
pour secondaire à l'université aussi on
a la même chose et donc c'est un défi de
société puis je pense que l'école doit
jouer un rôle éducatif à ce niveau là
vous par l'idée d'éduquer à l'intention
est là pourquoi ça ne ferait pas partie
justement aussi la mission d'école les
parents savent pas quoi faire avec ceux
de l'école on s'en soucie pont voudrais
juste un choeur dire mais justement on a
des jeunes qui vont finir l'université
sans qu'on leur montre que dans notre
société c'est aussi important d'avoir
des moments sans cellulaire quand tu
vois en restera en famille ou avec ton
copain à côté nous 40 est juste en train
d'y parfois et je pense que l'école doit
jouer un rôle éducatif et j'ai bon
espoir que l'éducation puisse un jour
entre participer à ce changement dalmat
oui j'ai lu récemment un livre par une
sociologue de communication elle
s'appelle claire balises puis elle elle
a étudié le titre c'est vraiment
évocateur ça s'appelle grandir entre
adolescents à sur l'internet et alec à
l'école et sur l'internet
et puis j'aimais beaucoup ça perspective
qui diabolise pas les réseaux sociaux
est encore les technologies comme le
téléphone intelligent parce qu'elle
explique canal faut les adolescents sont
en contact avec leurs familles sur le
terrain à l'école et en dehors de
l'école mais aussi sur les réseaux
sociaux de leur amitié se transporte
donc sur les réseaux sociaux et ailleurs
donc est-ce que vous qu'est ce que vous
pensez de ça vous est ce que c'est
vraiment une continuation de délai
et de la vie sociale de la socialisation
des enfants à travers les médias sociaux
moi je trouve sa perspective claire
baliste particulièrement intéressante
parce qu'il ne diabolise pas par contre
là où j'ai un petit problème c'est que
on laisse ces jeunes justement seul et
puis là on a des jeunes qui sont
toujours en train de faire plus d'une
chose en même temps et donc c'est il ya
peu ya pas de secret il est même si les
études c'est une étude qui est ça montre
quand on fait plusieurs choses en même
temps on devient meilleur pour faire
plusieurs choses en même temps
mais à ne jamais aussi bon que quand on
fait juste une chose alors donc comme et
vous quand vous voyez un peu de vie
alors s'il fait si je fais plusieurs
choses en même temps je vais devenir
meilleur le goût texte et en même temps
je vous parle tout le temps je vous
textes d'époque départ train de
critiquer tête je sais pas je suis trop
loin pour moi j'ai cherché les missions
pour la diffuser un faisceau facebook et
même temps mais le fait coûté vous êtes
vous écouter pendant que vous êtes sur
facebook et c'est ce que les jeunes ont
répondu
[Rires]
mais selon moi même si cette perspective
est restée plus important d'avoir des
perspectives qui ne diabolise pas cet
usage parce que moi j'ai série de france
où je participais à un colloque où je
voyais que les gens de gauche comme de
droite sont tout à fait d'accord avec
cette idée d'interdire le téléphone en
carrosse comme si c'était la seule
solution mais ce guide nous voyons ça on
interdire ça ne fonctionnera qu'à il
faut des règles et des règlements
l'interdît parement pas parce qu'on
balises mais il faut pas juste a été re
dire il faut éduquer les jeunes à un
usage qui soit plus socialement
acceptable qui honnit plus tôt pour le
dire aussi
marie clos alors moi j'ai juste
d'interdire pour moi ne marque
écoutez moi mes enfants quand il était à
l'école il n'y avait pas de téléphone
cellulaire
donc je mets question va peut-être un
peu ignares mais si je comprends bien
maintenant on encourage l'utilisation
des tablettes à l'école des pour
remplacer les livres il ya beaucoup
d'écoles privées qui ont des tablettes
pour répondre attendez les tablettes ont
fait légion dans les écoles privées
pendant les écoles où il vécut questions
de financement mais les tablettes vont
recevoir des messages aussi de commencer
quoi les règles par rapport aux
tablettes bill par an c'est le même des
filles vous savez là c'est le même défi
ça veut dire où les avoir un cellulaire
caché sous la table
ils ont une tablette qu'on a de façon
officielle mais pas dans ces écoles dans
ces écoles privées ou est partout il ya
des règles en place et tout est ce qu'on
essaye mais vous savez contrairement à
ce qu'on pourrait penser c'est justement
dans ces écoles
et là je vous dis pas que ça se passe
bien au début parce qu en première
secondaire dans ces écoles là les élèves
ne dorment plus parce que le soir
malheureusement les parents qui laissent
dormir avec leurs tablettes dans la
chambre s'il faut très bon parce que les
enfants sont sur les messages jusqu'à
des heures impossibles mais on a
justement parce qu'on est l'outil en
salles de classe et qu'on utilise à des
fins d'apprentissage on apprend à se
responsabiliser les jeunes dans les
études qu'on en fait nous mêmes
au début la gt pas responsable
maintenant le jeu arrive à résister à
plusieurs notifications avant de
répondre
il disposerait pas céder des gens on
voit qu'ils sont conscients alors que
d'autres jeunes sont peu conscients que
c'est un problème et je me dis ça veut
dire que parce que celles en salle de
classe
on arrive à leur apprendre un caddie bon
moment pour en faire deux d'autres
moments où ce qu'on devrait pas en faire
et ça ça permet de se questionner sur
tout ça dans les écoles ou à ce qu'on
dira penh où il n'ya pas de tablette
dont il se passe rien mais c'est faux on
va voir les jeunes on a fait des études
sur l'usagé des textos en salles de
classe dans les écoles où c'est interdit
de l'emmener à l'école dans les classes
28 sur 29 ont un téléphone avec eux il
ya une demoiselle qui faisait même
monsieur vous êtes naïf un peu je dis
mais pourquoi du bain la dernière qui
dit qu'un un poste parce qu'elle est
innée de vous montrer canada est donc
tout le monde en salle de classe alors
on n'est pas en train on serait croire
que c'était interdit mais finalement les
jeunes l'on commet pas fait envoyer que
paloma n'a rien retenu de votre leçon
qui a plus ça ne nous distrait
plus sur téléphone à l'âne est un taux
avait souhaité joyeux anniversaire à des
amis en plus au passage au fait c'est
quoi la voie de solution ses côtés
comment est ce qu'on fait pour mettre
les 10 son profil ou qu'ils sachent que
j'écoutais ce qu'il disait un il faut
pas interdire mais il faut peut-être que
responsabiliser les noms ok mais la
responsabilisation ça passe pas comme ça
ça lui convient pas ce que je dis ok tu
es responsable
oui oui je suis j'ai quand même
intéressant projet commun j'ai quand
même en voie puis reçoit deux textes
pendant que je suis en classe
comment est ce qu'on fait dans l'école
de ma fille il les laisse pas rentrer
dans les salons des classes avec le
téléphone c'est à dire qu'ils rentrent
avec le défend le téléfon il faut un
lieu quelque chose il est pointé les
confie cependant l'heure des classes
puis après éclairée dont le téléphone
puis tu vois les demies ma fille me dit
que les enfants et ils se promènent dans
les couloirs avec le téléphone est pas
le téléphone n'est pas petits dés de
l'addition de la vie normale mais à
l'intérieur de la classe non ils peuvent
pas l'utiliser
comment est ce qu'on fait pour que ce
soit possible
écoutez votre exemple est
particulièrement intéressant parce que
c'est ce qu'on avait répit dans les
enquêtes
là où les adultes et qui met six
règlements en place des poids semble
faire l'autruche
notre fille vous dis que dans le couloir
ils ont téléphoné comme par magie quand
on franchit la porte de la classe c
téléphone
nous ne leur est pas l'excellent moi
j'ai envoyé des textes puis peux pas
répondre parce que il doit laisser son
téléphone dans son casier pitt dans les
endroits où les casses yéyé il n'y a pas
de signal alors amis célèbres faire ça
veut dire on pense que les élèves on le
met dans casier mais dans ces écoles là
quand je dis on a fait une étude auprès
de plus de 1400 répondants les élèves
dans ces écoles où c'est interdit
ils ont quand même sûr ils vont pas le
mettre dans le casier c'est ça votre
fait elle est peut-être est responsable
ou à vous faire croire qu'elle est un
des deux
ça aurait pu fonctionner comme ça mais
en même temps l'idée c'est qu'on on se
fait croire que les élèves ont tous deux
porté ou quasi mais non ils sont dans le
couloir jusqu'avant la cloche la cloche
sonne on ne met dans sa poche
on veut pas le porter au casier il ya
juste sept minutes de battement la
récréation n'a pas le temps de retourner
aux cases il est donc qu est ce qui
arrive c'est qu'on l'a en classe ne fait
pas de doute évidemment il faut pas
sonner comme ce qu'on a avec pamela
paloma pardon mais à ce moment alors
c'est discret ça vibre pommes et les
notifications sur les téléphones
intelligents on voit le pian et ou
psychologiques vraiment beaucoup
d'études qui ont montré que on se sent
heureux de recevoir ces petites
notification je sens important et donc
toutes ces compagnies que la personne
qui a inventé les notifications elle ne
savais pas que ça allait créer une
dépendance planétaire mais on y est on
se sent vraiment dépendant de tout ça
donc c'est un mythe de penser que les
élèves comme par magie vont apporter au
kazoo c'est faux il le garde sur eux et
là ça devient tentant qu'est ce que tu
fais quand on commençait une discussion
entre ados à la récréation est ce que tu
veux vraiment attendre 75 minutes avant
de voir la suite
c'est certain que c'est tentant de
sortir ton téléphone et d'aller
professeur que je pense de 20 appels qui
y rentre à l'instinct apprenez prenez le
téléphone n'est pas parce qu'on sait
qu'on a entrevu
n'hésitez pas c'est là sur connexion d
après ses balles et claude qui vous
appelez au téléphone besoin de
professeurs merci beaucoup d'avoir
participé à nouveau aujourd'hui est
super ces débats dès qu'on a une chance
on vous rappelle alors c'était le
professeur thierry karsenti
professeur titulaire nologie de
l'information de la communication à
l'université de montréal un grand
spécialiste un gars qui connaît non
seulement ce qui se passe ici au québec
mais ailleurs dans le monde écoutez on
est prêt pour je pense notre question
thanh tâm canada nous allons dévoiler
cette question les internautes sur
facebook la connaissent des autres noms
et on va demander
on va donner leonardo non je vois pas de
6 ans
voyez pas de quoi dépenser gens pour
vous offrir le service de téléphone
intelligent bon tu vas quand tu vois
bien ouais
c'est même ça sert à quoi ces lunettes
là c'est un genre de projet d'accord
pour voir d'elle même et il faut que je
les change d'approché sur la question
via votre beauté un petit texte
c'est un marché puis vous allez voir
quand je fais comme ça ta vie parce que
des proches je le vois pas je lis pas pu
non plus alors ça c'est une autre
question cette semaine qu'on sait
pourquoi dépenser autant je veux faire
un tour de table rapide combien vous
dépensez je porte tout savoir la non
mais vous allez voir je me rends forfait
de quoi dire combien le départ oui oui
37 dollar et la poussée des textes de
jeunesse appels illimités des textos
illimités puis combien de julio tech de
50/50 mika quoi c'est tout 50 à dépasser
sa belle photo de données j'utilise pas
souvent ça c'est pour vous et pour toute
la famille commun c'est pour toute la
famille je dirai au total avec un fake
c'est juste mon garçon de 15 ans mon
mari et moi qui avons deux cellulaires
elle mon garçon n'a pas de données il a
seulement la téléphonie le texto est mon
mari
il utilise beaucoup d'internet et books
ont démoli par coûterait donc j'essaie
d'aider des médias c'est autour des 80
dollars pour les poulets je suis là
néandertal de la table ronde c'est à
dire que mon mari et moi on partage un
cellulaire moi je ne textent pas
j'envoie du courriel jetable est le soir
je m'informe ça beaucoup de combien une
trentaine de dollars aussi magnifique
mais en parfait état et de alors 55 trop
cher
mais j'ai plus de données mais j'ai
utilisées c'est appels illimités à
terraube est aussi mais aucun à domicile
canada 51 de rangement sont faux
panneaux mettre complètement sinon il
faut tout les nommez moi je fais affaire
avec ces petits chiens c'est le nom de
petit chai et ça vaut combien on payait
pas moins cher on est trois à la maison
qu'ils ont utilisés cellulaire c'est ma
fille de 15 ans mais 14 15
ma femme puis moi moi je les plus chers
parce que jeunes gens utilisent des
données à momas ici pour le travail
quand on sort c'est normal je suis
connecté tout le foot ou le lanl allons
la longueur de journée puis ma fille a
un paquet de données très restreint mais
quand même le tu disposes mais ça coûte
37 dollars les trois des trois c'est à
vous débrouiller très bien parce que moi
j'ai d'autres données par rapport à ça
mais d'abord j'aimerais qu'on est le
point de vue de françoise de perdus en
france qui nous a écrit je pense à
utiliser son téléphone pour nous écrire
sur facebook
je vais demander à marie claude très
bien lire vous allez jouer la française
aujourd'hui n'ont quand même pas
capables ils ont passé des missions vous
toujours les amis du canada dans notre
petite famille si ça coûte si cher ça
n'est pas tant le prix des abonnements
presque dérisoire mais souvent le prix
des dépassements alors mon mari et moi
avons chacun notre téléphone mais en
plus il faut payer pour ceux de nos deux
garçons il est arrivé à trois reprises
que ces mioches nous ont amenés à des
factures de 50 ou 60 euros euros pour
des bêtises de consommation de données
il s'en donne à coeur joie croyez moi on
a mis dans le coffre fort le téléphone
du plus jeune pendant une bonne semaine
le temps de lui faire comprendre qu'il
avait c'est la méthode forte parce qu'on
rit plus bah écoute et elle a raison je
pense que beaucoup de 40 des problèmes
avec ses excès de donner là mais jamais
un fils de 2 ans puis
de douces c'est là ils sont une
trentaine dans sa classe baba 26 27
puis elle était parmi les cinq qui ont
pas téléphone cellulaire ouais c'est
trop jeunes pim mais ma fille de 14 ans
il ya interdiction on a dit qu'on va
faire les choses comme il faut aux pieds
elle va voir la possibilité d'avoir ces
réseaux sociaux quand il va voir l'âge
pour l'avoir c'est à dire on rentre à
facebook pour avoir une compte il faut
avoir 16 ans alors on a changé ça c'est
pas très sympa maintenant je suis pas
c'est intéressant parce qu'à l'époque
moi j'ai dit à mon fils oui on va payer
le cellulaire c'est à dire l'achat de
cellulaires mais tu vas payer la facture
à chaque mois parce qu'il est va
commencer à travailler un peu alors ça
ça responsabilise ville
bonne idée alors on y va pour notre
deuxième jeu du de la grosse boule où je
cherchais quel était le nom de jeu mais
c'est facile de la grosse boule c'est
devant nous alors deuxième manche de la
grosse boule fonds pour 30 points
alors je vous rappelle les scores 00 20
et 10 alors pour tant de points pour un
forfait de niveau 3 typique des besoins
actuels des canadiens comprenant 1200
minutes
la messagerie texte et un gigaoctet de
données
c'est plus que moussa les plis canadiens
sont de combien mais ça coûte au canada
elle personnes en moyenne pour une seule
personne
c'est un moyen
au québec les prisons plus faible au
québec 95 d'accord celui qui gagne c'est
celui qui est le plus proche de la bonne
réponse je dirais de 60 60 dollars pour
maryse 65,65 le dire 66 pour couper
l'absolu faire - quel sort je redis à 59
alors ce qu'il veut et de la semoy qui
est plus proche de 74 ans et 67 sous à
gênés 65 kg
je sais madame moi je dis 95 et moi
alors 30 points de plus pour marie
claude guéant tient je sais quoi c'est
vrai ma lecture mais c'est tout avant
l'audience ses pages une orient semble
j'ai la conscience tranquille j'ai
absolument pas triché cette semaine en
tout cas alors écoutez ça se compare aux
plus américaine ça mais ça m'étonne 73
dollars aux états-unis au japon ses 89
dollars d'un pub cher mais si vous allez
par exemple à paris en france à rome
sydney et londres on parle ici de
forfaits pour seulement une trentaine de
dollars
et ici j'ai un croquis il fallait croque
une maquette qui va bouger vous allez
voir c'est au ccc interactif ça vous
montre les prix à travers le monde et
qu'ils étaient en vie ne nous souhaitons
qu'il en 1912 2012 donc ça veut une idée
des proportions pas des prix exact mais
aujourd'hui mais des proportions etats
unis 55 ans a diminué
non messieurs fonctionnent les deux
directions
mal alors ensuite qu'est ce que c'est ça
c'est le niger 20 c'est moins cher qu'au
canada le canada donc à qu'à l'époque 40
dollars ouais c'est quand même un
catamaran de 13,12 de l'allemagne voilà
je vous donne ses des proportions
d'accord il faut pas vous fiez aux chais
pas sa date de 1912
[Rires]
on a des prix très élevés
oui parce que c'était une grande à parce
qu'un peu de monde j'imagine c'est ce
qu'on nous dit mais c'est tout une
question de bande passante
c'est à dire qu'à une époque y avait
moins avec plus de concurrence entre les
compagnies qui avaient les bandes
passantes
moi je me suis quand j'ai acheté mon
premier téléphone cellulaire on
entendait très très clairement n'importe
où au canada et maintenant vous allez
remarquer vous sortez des grands centres
et vous entendez moins bien pourquoi
parce qu'on utilise de bande passante
avec des clients qui vont payer un peu
plus cher alors c'est le côté droit de
visite voilà le chat jarre une meilleure
réception très probablement mais ça veut
dire que vous allez dans le cinq
mégahertz communication cinq mégahertz
le l'avons même le lob mais je sais que
parfait qui fait le moi je n'ai rien ça
mais il le g3 et puis je connais alors
qu'il ya le 4g en ce moment oui c'est 4g
c'est au lt lt civile dit et puis il ya
le 4 il ya 2,5 g je pense que ça s'en
vient
ça sent vieillir est en train de se
révéler et puis j'entends pas bien
partout mais non mais là la qualité de
la voix c'est paul sermain
lles c'est qu'il ya une congestion de de
la qualité beaucoup de trafic
c'est pas la quantité qui vous payer ses
positions en forfaits plus chers ce qu'
il ya de l'argent les antennes il ya
incapacité pour recevoir les appels
peuple s'est pas développée pour la
quantité de cellules à qui a aujourd'hui
c'est pour ça qu'ils on pense aux 5 g
parce que il faut vraiment ouvrir la
porte pour la qualité des lignes qui
sont à lui et aux passants eh bien nous
avons sur ce qu est un autre spécialiste
de ça va être bon moment un espagnol moi
je fais là
les chroniques des technologies c'était
bien là c'est en tout cas ça me donne
des idées pour une prochaine mission
pour inviter une coupe de spécialistes
pour nous parler des réseaux au canada
comment est-ce que sinon on raconte des
histoires 12
bah écoutez je vais vous présenter
quelque chose qui est vraie oui puis
tout le monde peut résoudre ce qu'on le
dit on est accroché on aidé à quoi nous
au téléphone aux voix si ça s'appelle la
nnomo phobie c'est un nom scientifique
maintenant qu'ils existent qui est vrai
c'est peut-être dans le dictionnaire du
petit robert ça leur prend toujours du
temps à s'ajuster mais ça va ça sert 30
minutes oui alors écoutez voir on va
présenter ça avec son on va revenir en
arrière un peu et puis s'est préparée
par vincent maisonneuve
un reporter de radio comme cette affaire
moyens et ce biais en moyenne deux
heures et demie par jour à son téléphone
intelligent ça c'est grand pigeon par
année c'est six ans et demi qu d'une vie
hadji qui on utilise des téléphones
intelligents pour toutes sortes
d'excellentes raisons peut-être en train
de regarder sur votre cellulaire comme
ça n'empêche on commence à peine à
mesurer l'impact de cette technologie
assure nos cerveaux et sur nos rapports
avec les autres et est ce que démontrent
les récentes études scientifiques
c'est qu'une utilisation abusive peut
créer une dépendance changer le
fonctionnement notre cerveau on se fit
tellement notre cellulaire qu'il peut
réduire nos capacités cognitives notre
quotient intellectuel qu'il peut réduire
notre capacité à se concentrer provoqué
de l'anxiété de la solitude affecté
notre posture notre respiration et même
affecté la qualité de notre sommeil
comment dieu
c'est un véritable poison évidemment
aujourd'hui on met à la poubelle
on met l'accent sur les choses positives
aujourd'hui on l'a dit en début
d'émission mais quand même c'est pour ça
que les recommandations pour
l'utilisation pour les enfants de moins
de 3 ans et 8 août où tout recommance
qui après baby comédie c'est pour les
sommets si on se couche puis on a une
une communication avec les téléphones
qu'ils les regardent la lumière bleue il
va changer le cycle circadien de l'être
humain alors dormi ça va être plus
difficile les cas ils récupèrent ces
informations oui c'est intéressant
généraux ce que vous dites parce que moi
je suis avec mon fils à l'époque on
avait mis l'ordinateur à l'extérieur de
sa chambre pour pas que pendant la nuit
il se lève ils jouent à des jeux vidéo
j'ai comme l'impression qu'on devrait
faire la même chose des fois avec nos
téléphones
enfin reste au premier étage semeta
et puis moi je garde mon téléphone à
côté mais je déconnais que les données
toutes les ouailles faille et tout ça
avant mais couché comme la position
comme ça ça offre ici des plus de 80 il
aurait alors c'est toujours un problème
de dos à côté
si vous encore davantage sur les dangers
médicaux pour ausculter squelettiques ou
même pour le cerveau les langes et on a
trois en portage avait fait quelque
chose ça mais malgré l'essai avec oui je
vous jure il s'appelle les téléphones
cellulaires les plus populaires sont
dangereux selon une enquête de siby si
ce n'est pas ça et puis aussi c'est sur
notre page web de tam tam se pense que
c'est en 2017
le 27 mars 2010 cette affaire et puis
aussi si nous et si notre défensive leur
menace est vraiment notre santé bonne
question des marocains point
d'interrogation je pense qu'au fort ça
c'est des palmes à l'aller dc sign on
maintenant si tu es quelqu'un d'autre
que je mentionnerai pas parce que c'est
moins comparé la vitesse de votre
cellulaire à celle des autres pays
ça c'est une question que je veux
maintenant vous posez grâce au jeu de la
grosse boule
mais je veux gagner les scores sont sans
appel c'est 50 ici dit cela mais des
héros paloma alors comment se compare
notre vitesse c'est important de savoir
ça sinon on va passer des heures sur
facebook et s'est affiché quelque chose
qui s'y affiche pas un vrai ou faux la
vitesse de connexion de votre cellulaire
au canada et l'une des dix plus rapides
au monde vrai ou faux pas s'il devrait
ou faux vrai vrai vrai vrai nom parce
que qu'est ce que vous dites magie magie
dit vrai mais là vous regardez un jeu
mais vous faut la vitesse de connexion
d'un cellulaire au canada et l'une des
dix plus rapidement ouais ouais ouais
bon c'est vrai je me fie leonardo alors
c'est faux la détecte alors on peut même
pas accordé 50 points ah c'est vous
marie claude a emporté par défaut alors
voici malgré sa personne de certains
clients le canada en fête se retrouve
dans ce cas comme 20e notre alors on est
quand même assez rapide il ya 160 et 19
pays dans le monde et plus je suis à
chaque mois y en a un qui n'est est pas
seulement dans les vingt premiers
d'accord j'ai des détails sous d'avoir
ça les détails écoutez je nom des fois
j'ai des réponses aux questions ok alors
on est derrière des nations comme
singapour israël l'australie l'espagne
mais devant le royaume uni est bien aux
mains des américains qui eux devraient
se contenter d'une vitesse moyenne
seulement de 10 mégabits par seconde la
vitesse mondiale moyenne est de 13,6
notre vitesse nous est de 19 on est en
fait 15e
pour être précis donc on n'était pas
loin de la bonne réponse mais pas tout à
fait voilà c'est tout pour aujourd'hui
on revient sur notre histoire des
spécialistes qui vont nous parler des
réseaux canada ah oui on pourrait faire
sa peau est toujours à la recherche d'un
bon je sais que vous allez changer
d'écurie là parce qu'elle voulait pas
comme ça je le sujet d'abord c'est bien
dommage mais cette semaine la semaine
prochaine je vais très satisfait nimani
clos avec des militaires dans le studio
est ce que vous savez pas c'est que
quand il m'a dit qu'on est assis l'un à
côté de l'autre
c'est tellement ans ont fait du snap
chatons fait jamais de téléphone on est
face à une fois aux étapes les uns ouais
ouais ok bah écoute et merci beaucoup
paloma martinez je veux signer paloma
travaille aujourd'hui à la section
espagnole de radio-canada et à la
dernière minute anne-marie vont a dû
s'occuper de ses priorités salle
l'espace autochtone et paloma au pied de
vie a accepté de venir à l'émission
merci à vous tous et puis marie-jo ben
c'est toujours un plaisir pratiquement
centenaire d'entre eux qu'à ça fait des
années de retard
et puis amaris marc merci beaucoup cette
semaine
et puis leonardo jamais nommer ses
cuisses tiens oui mais non tout petit
peu fantastique où on salue à quelqu'un
les deux les deux on avait ça pour lui
le mal merci bien
l'étudiant merci beaucoup